let's continue let's uh let's play some
speed run let's play one five minute
game
and here we go we got 2471 opponent
gavin pmf let's go guys
we'll talk about this another day let's
do some speed running and
guess what if i'm worth my salt if i'm
worth my salt
i've played the accelerated dragon and
i've advocated for it it's time for me
to put it to the test against someone
really really strong
[Music]
okay i already don't like the fact that
he spent four seconds on knight takes d4
but
but okay i'm kidding this should be
three
okay so this is theory of the
accelerated dragon we've seen this a
million times ladies and gentlemen
now the move is simply to castle here
okay this guy's 1410 minute
just noticing that this guy is is rated
1410 minutes
[Music]
well the move is a5 here
the move is a5 here now what is the idea
of
a5 who can tell me what what the idea of
a5 is let's
we're not concluding anything we're
playing theory
what is the idea of a5
so it is to expand on the on the queen
side but also we play the move a4 and
the reason behind the move a4 is we are
distracting one of his two pieces
from its defense of the e4 one and if
this trade-off is good for black we take
the central pawn
for uh for for the side pawn the problem
with this line this is the main line
is that white gets his and this is
correct knight b5 white gets his bishop
to b6
and white has all of these threats that
he poses
uh against my queen and against my own
so white gets the initiative
but i do get the central pawn so i think
here that the move is
i don't remember it's either rook a6 or
it's a d6
i think it's d6 i i think oh camera is
molding
oh sorry okay guys well you might have
to just tolerate this
okay it looks like we're good okay so
now we need we need to get our knight
back knight f6
and uh he's probably going to go knight
b6 or c4 now we have to move our rope to
a6 we got to move our rook away from
being attacked
knight takes c8 here i think is the only
move and he spends about five seconds on
it
um anyways
okay queen e2
i'm kidding now uh let's occupy the
center by playing the move d6 to d5
your cam is getting disconnected oh is
it going back and forth
all right so he attacks the pawn
we should probably defend it with a move
rook to d8
all right guys let's focus on the game
please sorry for the
rook e1
okay that's a weird move well what we
can try to do is
make sure that our center here is a
little bit more solid let's play e6
just to reinforce the pawn on on d4 now
i'm looking at this knight and i'm
saying the positioning of this knight on
c6
i i think can be improved further what
we can try to do is go knight a5 and
then knight to c4 if he moves his bishop
of course
we can play the move knight to c4 he
goes to a to d1 instead
okay um now what we can try to do i'm
looking at this knight on b5 and i'm
saying well i want to get rid of this
knight
this knight is his strongest piece so
what we're going to do is we're going to
try to get my knight over to d6 in order
to either trade his knight or to
displace it
h3 okay that is a very odd move let's go
knight to d6
well still man it should but but
basically we have already
completed our development he no longer
really has
any pieces to access this with okay so
let's go rook b6
i think this guy's legit by the way
okay bishop g5 definitely
very odd moves but so far i think i've
got a pretty
pretty reasonable position actually oh
does he want to go
here wait what is this
does he somehow trap my exchange in some
super obscure way
are you serious he wants this and
this oh my god
oh my god on the rook d5 if you play
okay
okay okay this should be six
or five seconds
there it is okay now we're gonna
sacrifice
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sacrifice my exchange in order to get
the dark squares
now let's calculate how many moves i
have to make so if he's got two and a
half minutes that is 100 150 seconds
five seconds to remove
that's another 30 a3
okay i mean i'm not saying anything i
think he's probably legit
but uh it's just style of play is
extremely strange
thank you www for this help
i mean i'm not making this up you guys
can see what i mean
okay rookie
yeah this is some very weird g3 okay
well let's try to
let's try to lighten the load by maybe
trading off uh
the dark squared bishop here
all right well he goes back to the v6
not corona another five gifted subs to
the community
thank you
the issue is i'm kind of cramped here he
somehow brilliantly
maneuvered his bishops over in order to
tie me down
and i think i walked into c4
okay that now there's something very
weird about his play
very weird
i need a napkin one sec
hot sauce
okay yeah this guy is
is out playing the hell out of me a5 and
we're just gonna we're gonna go back and
forth and try to flag him
because he is going to spend five
seconds per move all the way to the end
i'm gonna play for a win here
okay he's just going back and forth
oh now we go c4 oh i shouldn't have
allowed this guys
okay let's go back to g7
i mean it seems like this guy plays some
moves really really well and then he'll
go
all of a sudden back and forth i mean
i've never seen
anybody ever play like this and also the
time consumption is crazy it is
literally
every single move
okay well i only have to hold out for
another minute and with every passing
move
we are oh no he's gonna beat me though
he started to accelerate the pace
of his play a little bit yeah this is
he's definitely
definitely doing something i mean look
at this he's just out playing me here
probably some bishop f7 nonsense oh my
g5
i mean i want is this fun for these
people no he's gonna mate me though
oh my god queen e4 e
i'm not able to chat on this account
okay so if i can hold out another 30
seconds because
this guy is so brazen that he's going to
take five seconds per move even when he
dips down look at this look at this
garbage
look at this garbage okay i have 20 more
seconds to hold out ladies and gentlemen
okay now i need to find a way to not get
mated in the next four moves i mean i
should be able to do that
kinky one
okay okay i think we got this guys i'm
cautiously optimistic
i'm cautiously optimistic he's gonna
take five seconds on bc
okay bishop c5
okay now he stops and now he blunders a
fork and i'm actually winning all right
and we get to 2400 now unfortunately i
think the last five
five game five minute games i've played
have been against cheaters
that's how you beat these these guys
i mean i'm sorry but if you're going to
cheat
now at least win the game thank you
anonymous gift
to shock creeks by her tier 2 sub
all right let's uh let's do the accuracy
check here
i know you guys don't see this i mean
there's just too many of them i'm almost
very
i'm almost cynical when it comes to
reporting because it's so
the chess world has been so overrun
unfortunately
sadly with with these people it's just
unbelievable
thank you gimped x for the five gift it
subs
to the comunidad yeah
queen f2 is best a3 is best
oh my g3 is best yeah he made it so
obvious
literally okay let me show you guys this
thank you give them to x appreciate it
yeah this is he made it so obvious oh my
god
ladies and gentlemen this c6 it was so
obvious that this was best c6 and bishop
c5
and here's you get this king h2 and king
g2
was top moves i mean
i've never seen anybody make it more
obvious
all right i'm gonna write something
funny
thank you not corona for the sub and
bhuta zemu appreciate it
[Music]
all right let's go e4
and let's go let's go with the grand
prix attack now i have played
okay actually no let's play open silly
let's go knight f3 and d4 let's play an
open sitzillion
d4 cd knight d4
and john playing the what this is called
the timing off
and the time enough is is named after a
soviet grandmaster mark time on off
who some of you may have heard of he's
he was good he was
got crushed by fischer in the candidates
match but nonetheless he was incredibly
good
and white has many ways to develop
either of his bishops the one
way that i like to develop is to go g3
that is a very popular move feed
catering the bishop onto a good square
and then castling quickly
um i've played this myself many times in
over-the-board chess
and i think it's a pretty pretty solid
idea
okay so plan f6 bishop g2 yeah
and john going h5 which is the
fashionable move by the way
this is the fashionable move and black
quickly trying to ram
down h4 down my throat and for that
reason it's important to stop h4
and the way that we are going to do that
is just by dropping the knight back to
f3 the knight fulfills two purposes here
i had a pro chesley giving it's eric
rosen that went just like this
number one it stops h4 number two you
could envision a future scenario
where we clamp down on black center if
black allows it of course by playing e5
that's what happened in my game against
eric
and it was crushing but first we need to
castle we need to castle
we can't can't do much with our king
stuck in the center
yeah you can play h4 but you can you can
also play h3
um i faced this a couple of times in
tournament chess and
i've also experimented with the move h3
in order to meet h4 with g4 kind of
you know okay i think we're exactly
following my game against eric
and here let me let me remember
yeah i'll have to look it up afterwards
now there's a couple of very interesting
approaches that black could
that why could take a position like this
but let's do what i did against eric
and let's sacrifice a pawn now what i
what i want you to notice here is the
fact that
black has not developed
his light scored bishop nor is basically
the
part of the queen side is not developed
black is not castled
so it may not seem like much
but the reality is i have a pretty big
development advantage when we have a
development advantage
we want to do our best to open up the
center so
who can suggest a method of opening up
the center it comes at the cost of a
pawn
but it gives us a very big initiative it
gives us
a quick way to develop the rest of our
pieces
and it more most importantly gives us a
an avenue to opening up the center so
the move is e5
right we sacrifice the pawn we do that
to lure the queen into the center of the
board now that's not a good thing
for the queen to be in the center in so
much traffic because amidst so much
traffic because we can get the bishop
out later we can attack the queen with
tempo
we open up the e file and we could use
that e file we could put a rook there
things start to get quite unpleasant for
black from a practical standpoint
right and and importantly we don't go
upon f4 later we go we go
takes and now we go bishop to f4
and now the queen has a very limited
supply of squares that it can go to
essentially only two
and both of those squares have a
drawback that is attached
to that square we'll talk about that uh
based on where black goes
okay now obviously and i
i don't like to use that word too much
but obviously we don't want a queen
trade
and the move should come very naturally
here because we don't want a queen trade
we don't want to position our queen on
some god forsaken square
so the most harmonious square is clearly
e2 using that e file
and paving the way for perhaps a rook to
come to d1 now we are not looking for
a quick knockout here i've sacrificed a
pond for sort of a more sustained
initiative right this isn't something
where i'm going to win in the next three
moves
it's i'm just trying to make it very
hard for black to actually finish his
development
and we're going to start bringing pieces
in slowly nurturing my initiative and
eventually
transmuting that initiative hopefully
into an attack against his king
the thing that that hurts black here is
that jon can never really castle with a
clear conscience because if he castles
he's going to have that pawn that's
sticking out on h5 and that's
not good for anyone all right so here
we have a very interesting way to try to
root out
this bishop on on on a5
and we can do it through the let through
the
aid of another pawn sacrifice who can
spot what i'm talking about now the
reason we would want to get rid of this
bishop is that
if we get rid of this bishop we might be
able to stick our own bishop on d6 and
permanently paralyze white a black's
bishop basically like an elephant
sitting on black's chest so
bishop e3 would be a good concept but i
don't want to give away my bishop for
his bishop
i want to give away my knight for his
bishop and for that to happen
we have to lure black's queen onto a
vulnerable spot so that we can kind of
semi-fork the queen and the bishop
perhaps with a move like knight a4 and
the move is a3
so we are offering up a second pawn
queen takes p2 and
if queen takes p2 happens we're going to
refine our strategy slightly we're not
going to go knight a4 immediately
we're going to maybe make them a bishop
e5 first but no no let's go knight a4
actually
knight a4 would be very strong there
i don't know if this is making sense
okay and now of course we are going to
go knight a4
we are going to eliminate this bishop
and now we are going to try our best to
put the bishop on d6 but
um we got to be careful about how we do
this
because if we play rook d1 if we play
rook d1 then he's going to beat us to
the punch he's going to play d5
and he's going to intercept the rook
we're not going to be able to play
bishop d6 so we we first need to at
least discourage him from playing d5
and then we can play rook t1 how do we
discourage him from playing d5
we can play the move c4 yes nice very
nice now he can still play d5
that's that's not disallowed but in
doing so he's going to have to reckon
with the opening of the c file and given
how undeveloped he is given how weak as
king is
opening up any file comes with um
you know a lot of damage so he either
has to keep the files closed and allow
us
essentially to put a bishop on d6 or he
has to go d5 and open up this evol
notice how i'm
forcing john to make a decision here
that's something you want to try to do
most
a lot of in blitz is make your opponent
make decisions
force him into choosing between two
tempting or
non-tempting alternatives because that's
going to increase the chances that your
opponent lands in time pressure
thank you radio math appreciate it
all right now so we can we
yeah now we can go rook 81 it's
definitely time
okay now we're going to take that pawn
and although john has tried to open up a
peephole for this bishop it doesn't help
because his pieces are just too cramped
this is this is just losing
he should have gone d5 now oh we have a
really five head move
the first thing that everybody should
see is the potential for a discovery
when you have a potential for a
discovery you want to be very methodical
in
how you approach it you want to look at
every possible square for the bishop
you want to look at every possible
square for the bishop you also want to
associate it with the hanging pawns
and pieces i see that there is a pawn on
g7 which is on a dark square
it is undefended can i access it with a
bishop i sure can
i can play bishop f8 that's right that's
a very nice i always like to put my
piece
on a square where my opponent's piece
initially is like putting my bishop on a
fader my knight on g8
that's always a good feeling okay now
funny thing is we can take f6 but i
don't even want to give this bishop away
even if for the cost of a pawn
i want to keep my dark squared bishop
that's how much it means to me
that's how much it means to me
and now all right
now we're going to chase the queen away
we're going to play bishop to e3 i'm a
little bit short of time so i'm going to
play a little faster here we're just
going to chase the queen around for a
bit
now we're going to centralize our own
queen
we're going to centralize our own queen
and then we're going to get in there
we're going to go rook to d6 and rook d1
and we're going to go in for the kill
also the move c5 makes a lot of sense
here
okay we can oh actually we can snag this
pawn on b7
and we can drop the bishop back to c6
now he can't take it because he's pinned
and he's actually pinned all over the
place you can see
this is a nice game actually this is a
very nice game
and i won a pretty similar game actually
against eric eric rosen in the protest
league which i'll maybe show you guys
afterward
and this is pin city that's right now we
can take this rook
and the game is over because we are also
going to win as bishop and
yeah everything just falls good very
good game john
i appreciate it um
i'm going to open it up in chess space
because the server is going to reset
great games we're going to go over that
very very quickly
reference here i faced this move
i faced this move oh h5 itself is pretty
new so
normally oh h5 itself is kind of rare
a6 and after castles now
h5 is a lot more common john so
this is an interesting distinction a6 is
very commonplace here i actually forgot
about that and the reason is that knight
db5 i think
is considered to be a nasty move but sam
samuel thank you f
paula for the five gifted stuff thank
you so much f paula
for the five tier one subs to the
community
really really appreciate it so vladimir
bello has played this
okay so i decided to play knight f3
and um the critical moment really comes
here
the critical moment really comes here
yes in ereditsky rosen i was exactly
right
i literally had this exact position
against eric rosen
and i and i played e5 we literally are
following my game against rosen
from 2017 pro chess league you guys can
see the 100 2017
that's pretty crazy 95 so this happened
eric played queen d4 we're still
following my game against rosen
and here was the first deviation um
eric played the move bishop e7
in order to pave the way for that queen
to to get away now let me show you guys
quickly my game against eric and how
that how that went
i'm gonna copy that game to my
annotation it was a longer game
now what you'll see against eric is that
i did something very very similar to
what i tried to do against john i put my
bishop on d6 so i paralyzed him
by not letting him push the d-pawn and
the reason he can't get his b-pawn
move moving either is because uh it is
it is pinned by the bishop so
it's incredibly hard for black to even
really make a move so i kind of slowly
clamped down on his position he didn't
manage to play b5 i think zeus bought
coflex but
you guys can see how bad this was
eventually eric got his bishop out
but he did so at the cost of a pawn and
then he lost another pawn
and and another pawn and he tried to
create some
and another pawn and uh ultimately was
too many pawns and i
promoted them so it was a nice game it
was a nice
game pretty smooth and and he never
really got out of that so
i i actually do think that bishop c5
maybe this line is quite dubious
anyways so john you played queen before
now this move a3 right
if queen takes b2 would have followed
then i go knight to a4
and i don't care about the second pawn i
really don't after queen d4 we can even
try to go c4 and trap his queen
for example in this line the queen is
literally trapped
oh the queen is literally trapped and uh
i think john you were correct to not
take the pawn but
sadly and this move c4 is the crucial
one i think c4 is the most important
move in the whole game
and and notice that we're we're not
playing work
we're sorry we're not playing rock a to
d1 because of d5 and
all it takes is one moment like this to
really turn the game around
because you're gonna get your bishop out
to d7 and as soon as you do black's
position starts to breathe again
so c4 essentially puts black in a very
big bind because if you go d5 now
then c takes d5 knight takes d5 now that
c file gets open
so i can play rook c1 immediately i can
also preserve my bishop first which i
probably would have done
and then after something like f6 i mean
you guys can see that this c file is
going to devastate black unfortunately
so
it's an irresolvable dilemma and john i
would say maybe your last hope was to go
d5 here and
you know kind of yolo it i mean this
opens up the position but at the very
least your bishop actually gets some
mobility to develop itself to e6
so even though white is better i
actually don't think the white is
decisively better here
i think after d6 um
you know it's it's it's it's it's just
pretty bad but
oh i see it was a slip yeah no d5
definitely gives black
i think something it's still very
unpleasant let me be clear but
uh and in any case john that was a great
game we followed followed one of my
games for like 13 moves so
that's pretty cool man and once again i
appreciate
everything you do thanks for the games
john
um now the server is is offline so we
won't be going back to the live chat
screen we'll just be ending the stream
from the chess base scene but
uh once again guys it turned out into a
handsome two and a half hour stream so
definitely happy to have streamed i'm
gonna hit the sack guys
so i'll see you guys later and thanks
everybody have a great
rest of your night or morning wherever
you are stay safe